لذا أصبح بات سيبولوني مستشارًا للبيت الأبيض
في عام 2018 عندما كنت لا تزال
تعمل كمستشار للأمن القومي ،
فما رأيك في المقتطفات التي
سمعناها عن شهادته اليوم جيدًا ،
أعتقد أنها كانت تكشف تمامًا عما
كان يقوله لدونالد ترامب وبدقة تامة
مسائل تتعلق
بالدستور والقانون ، كان
لدي بالتأكيد بعض الخلافات مع
بات في محاولة لقمع كتابي ،
لكنني أريد أن أقول في هذه المناسبة
وفي العديد من الأمور الأخرى ، لكن في هذا الصدد على
وجه الخصوص ، وقف طويل القامة وفعل
الشيء الصحيح الذي قاله للرئيس
أفضل حكم قانوني له أه وإه يجب أن
نقدم له جولة من التصفيق على
صموده إن لم يكن
وسام الحرية الرئاسي لماذا ليست فكرة جيدة
أعتقد أننا فقط نسلمه الآن
أم لا أريد أن أسأله
يبدو كما لو  الرئيس
وهذه ليست ظاهرة جديدة لكن
الرئيس سيذهب إلى الخبراء
حتى الأشخاص الموالين له مثل
بات سيبولوني إذا كنت
مستشار البيت الأبيض في نوفمبر 2020 كنت
مخلصًا  لدونالد ترامب أه احصل على نصيحة
لا تستمع إلى النصيحة ولا تلتفت إلى
النصيحة واستمر في التسوق حتى
ينتهي بك الأمر مع هذه
المجموعة من غير الأسوياء مثل مايكل
فلين وسيدني باول أم ، هل هو فقط غير
قادر على سماع شيء جيد عندما
يتعلق الأمر  مصلحته الشخصية
الجواب هو أنه لا يستمع إلى أي شخص
آخر ولكن أعتقد أنه من المهم أيضًا
أن نفهم بينما لا شيء
لم يفعله دونالد ترامب بعد الانتخابات
أه فيما يتعلق بالكذبة حول
تزوير الانتخابات ، لا يمكن الدفاع عن
أي منها.
إنه خطأ يمكن الدفاع عنه أيضًا كما قال بعض الأشخاص
بما في ذلك في اللجنة
المعلقين أن هذا كان بطريقة ما
انقلابًا مخططًا له بعناية
يستهدف الدستور ، فهذه ليست الطريقة التي يقوم بها
دونالد ترامب بالأشياء التي ينتقل
من نصف فكرة واسعة إلى
خطة أخرى  الذي يسقط ويظهر
آخر أن هذا ما كان
يفعله لأنني لا أقول أي شيء يمكن الدفاع عنه ولكن
عليك أن تفهم
طبيعة مشكلة دونالد ترامب.  هل
يستخدم استعارة حرب النجوم اضطرابًا
في القوة وليس هجومًا على
ديمقراطيتنا ، إنه دونالد ترامب
يبحث عن دونالد ترامب إنه حدث مرة واحدة في
العمر لا أعرف أنني
أتفق معك في أن تكون  أه عادل مع
كل الاحترام الواجب أه لا يجب أن
يكون المرء
بارعًا في محاولة الانقلاب أه
لا أتفق مع ذلك كشخص
ساعد في التخطيط للانقلاب ، نعم ليس هنا
ولكنك تعرف أماكن أخرى
يتطلب الأمر الكثير من العمل وهذا  لم يكن
ما فعله هو مجرد التعثر
من فكرة إلى أخرى ، وفي النهاية
أطلق العنان للمشاغبين في مبنى الكابيتول
لأنه ليس هناك شك ، ولكن ليس هناك شك في
الإطاحة بالدستور لكسب المزيد من
الوقت لإعادة الأمر إلى
الولايات لمحاولة إعادته.  المشكلة وإذا
كنت لا تعتقد أنك ستبالغ في
رد فعلك ، فأنا أريد أن أسأل عن متابعة
عندما كنا نتحدث عن ما هو
قادر على ما عليك القيام به
لتتمكن من التخطيط
لانقلاب وأنت  استشهد
بخبرتك في التخطيط لانقلابات أنا لست goi  ng للدخول
في التفاصيل ولكن آه الانقلابات الناجحة
جيدًا لقد كتبت عن فنزويلا في
الكتاب وأه اتضح أنه لم يكن
ناجحًا ليس لأن لدينا الكثير
لنفعله بها ولكني رأيت ما تطلبه
الأمر لمعارضة  حاول قلب
رئيس منتخب بشكل غير قانوني
وفشلوا في فكرة أن دونالد ترامب كان
نصف كفء مثل المعارضة الفنزويلية
أمر مثير للضحك ، لكني أعتقد أن
هناك شعورًا بأنك هذه
الأشياء الأخرى التي لا تخبرني بها على الرغم من أنني
أعتقد أنني  بالتأكيد هناك